mais rené savary big show in france
[Applaudissements]
jean schultheis jean pierre mader diallo
jean pierre mader macumba macumba ce
soir si c'est la dernière demain c'est
laid
tout fait pour mon fils a omis de payer
200 mille euros sauf deux sont mis nos
voix la sacem et 200000 euros au fisc
avec les pénalités en et autour du
mystère à mignon star 80 c'était un
immense carton comme vous avez pu le
transformer en un immense fiasco et
s'est même essayé de nous à moi un petit
mois et un concert n'a pas trouvé mieux
comme plan de redressement est le seul à
proposer toi donc mais en bon serviront
d'un concert nogueira stade je t'en
supplie ça va pas être facile on leur a
promis des vacances et des vacances
ça n'a plus alors on va les prendre avec
le coeur en fait sincère vu l'ampleur du
projet on a décidé de faire appel à un
professionnel
je ne vous demanderai pas l'atteindre
mots et level mais je vais tout faire
vous amener à un niveau correct pour des
gens de traque
j'ai tout alice des ménages les plus
grandes stars us des années 80 y'a plus
qu'à et j'ai la chair de barry white
yes donna summer ou whitney houston
enfin ils sont tous morts rouler - sont
disponibles
on a été chercher des stars
internationales la couleur de gand on
attend semaine fire ils sont plus de 2
des sabres ina c'est plus compliqué oui
elle est devenue une nonne tard 86 sabré
la passe à 80 c'est le seigneur qui
t'appelle
[Musique]
m
et ça je chope
à son bord
tu es tout seul d'habitude et de jeux
avec des copines attaqué devant venir un
master c'est à son lycée bah oui parce
la mecque